[Music]
and this week we got hangover pill and a
dolphin translator take it away
Tiffany oh yeah so for a first story
there is this pill that claims it can
cure or prevent hangovers I can finally
drink alcohol now and that's the only
reason why you don't cuz you get a
hangover
well the symptoms sound like a hangover
because it sounds like I go straight to
hangover and nothing else I don't get
any benefits I [ __ ] start drinking
beer and halfway through it I just get a
throbbing headache and I'm like why do
people enjoy this [ __ ] and I can't
breathe hmm literally cannot breathe I'm
like oh maybe you're really allergic
I'll never do like why do people enjoy
that [ __ ] I'm just saying if he already
said he's allergic to it but then you're
like maybe you're learning I think I'm
pretty allergic how fast does the pill
work Tiffany pretty much the way it
works is you take the pill before you
drink and then in the morning it's
promised to not give you a hangover Wow
it's like when is the same type of
pepcid ac but then no custody maybe I
should try that pepcid ac no that's just
for the glow it's not the previous you
know what also helps and you actually
take something else beside the pill
before you drink it called water yeah
and the exact same thing oh really yeah
so when you drink so you take a shot you
take a drink of water
take a shot take a drink of water and it
helps you will not get a hangover the
reason why you'll have a hangover it's
because you're dehydrated how much water
pressure shot I'm doing a lot of water
so I don't get any numbers so that's the
secret to no hangover because people
will just be drinking and drinking and
drinking and you forget to drink water
all these developers are like no David
no oh yeah just got it what is it is
like a concentrated form of water in a
pill so no so this is Eddie 23 years old
it would be an Asian guy yeah Sookie
Asian guys always have hangovers
yeah so he said the reason why you
wanted to create this product is because
he's missing that enzyme that breaks
down alcohol his liver
definitely cause me to that's
almost I just get allergy and alcohol
poisoning in my five seconds
so on a trip to Tokyo he tried some of
the Japanese methods to cure a hangover
and so he found that a lot of the
ingredients that were in these home
remedies they actually helped him with
his hangover so and he created this
product called fly by life I didn't one
slice of orange and two pills yeah he
partnered up with the biochemistry
person I'm telling you they were able to
create a biochem this person and they
thank you I blink for a second what is
the orange have to do with anything
mister flavor was a lot of vitamin C in
there so yeah this this is what's in it
it's all science I would love to read it
dear Tom science not superstition cool
many people rely on write an old wives
tale to guide our decision on healthy
drinking bye bye is the public of more
than a year of rigorous research in
partnership with a PhD [ __ ] in biotech
forgiven retention over 100 combination
of the highest-quality ingredients to
finalize the formula for FRA by libera
hydrogenate vitamin C and alpha lipoic
acid this is why you want me to read it
I know what I don't want to read this
all by hydro I'll give a [ __ ] about that
nerd [ __ ] okay basically it's oh what
the [ __ ] is Bill fickle
yeah it's why they always gotta use
Latin s terms nobody [ __ ] speaks that
[ __ ]
no sniffles what are they trying to do
talk to the demons yes so this is for
people like him or like like me and Joe
can't really process alcohol to drink
alcohol no so that's why he created it
for his own problem and I just solve a
lot of people like but he's saying like
this for people that can break down
alcohol this can help with the next day
hangover Oh so what's of both people
yeah what I like about it is you know
instead of someone like me who goes well
there's no choice I can't drink maybe I
should just stay away from alcohol
he found a solution for me to find a new
drug to enjoy yes I really like that it
might be for the the redness student
Asian grow so when people tend to drink
a lot the liver works hard to break
break up the alcohol but when it doesn't
have enough enzymes to break up the
alcohol it leaves behind this certain
toxin that causes the hangover the next
day that's why people get like headache
so guess what I won Josh but water does
help with hangovers I think this is
specifically for Asian people no it's
it's that's what happens when your liver
runs out of that particular enzyme
because it only has so much come on bro
they did a year of rigorous research
they know I want to know what that
[ __ ] enzyme is because I wonder if
it's important it's called I can tell
you what it's called
it is important but is it the same
enzyme for milk because they're saying
there's a correlation between people who
can't drink milk okay you know I think
there are two different enzymes up but
it's I don't think it's important
because it's not natural for us to
always seek things that are high in
alcohol content in nature as animals
yeah how come why people can drink it
they've probably developed it over years
too so you know they would drink alcohol
before even water oh and it's also
second that sorry Viking days are
nutritious oh that's what is the toxin
that's left behind it's called a set of
assets how dare hide another nerd term
that I'm not going to care about that's
not hot enough left behind in your body
that causes a hangover so this pill
makes it go away it makes it go away
it's [ __ ] Merlin for the stomach hmm
I saw fry next sorry
scientists are predicting that by 2021
we'll be able to translate the dolphin
language Wow why do we need to just do
like get information from the sea and
why do we need to do why do we eat what
I can't believe you have to ask why do
we even need to ask
we need to speak to dolphins ASAP what's
dope is because they're already so
gangsta verity talk like gangsters and
they're like what why don't you want to
talk to dolphins we have against
dolphins I didn't say that no cuz you're
so surprised I don't know why do we even
need to do that [ __ ] talk to another
species and you're so angry I was angry
at all actually I'm actually very very
happy and excited once you're slowly
like that why don't copy the [ __ ]
isn't talked about okay and then I went
with all I see why because then we can
get information from the sea I dare do
not [ __ ] reporters tell me how the
starfish is doing thank you want to know
the same reason why the [ __ ] we need
adult readers me to talk it's like when
you got problems at your friends you
just got to talk yeah well I don't we're
gonna talk about yeah I need a shaker
dolphin fin and figure it out if what's
up I've never spoken to anyone outside
of human why need to visit now thinking
to like we don't communicate with others
well I know exactly what the Dolphins
are going to say fish and rape that's it
I'm saying cuz they're gangsters of the
seats right fish fish fish well what if
they blow your mind all fish bakery what
if they say something else like what's
mine blowing there's Russian submarines
right now in the [ __ ] Cuban sea
then it goes with my theory that you
were making fun of no I never fart it's
not as to what you're talking about is
that they've been interviewing all the
sea creatures like just in our channel
ocean need and I'll do that I'm not that
creative I was even thinking that afar
do you know what what do you think so I
think here what they're going to talk
about they're gonna talk about fish and
raped and also how they kidnap orcas and
all the other stuff that they do that's
cool I want to hear that I wonder if
they have different dialects of dolphins
my African dialect then the Pacific
Ocean dialects what the [ __ ] that'll be
dubbed in clicks ooh [ __ ] I don't know
cuz will be crazy is like you know how
Boston's are all over the world right
like they cover miles and miles of the
world in the sea
I don't usually stained like darker warm
water but they travel right so they have
one language there one above us cuz they
travel so many miles but their one
language for the humans so stupid so
many language yeah they are saying that
like the uses of this could be so far
like us maybe they already have dolphins
that are trained to attack [ __ ]
all that hi bye
karate dolphins to locate lost swimmers
and like underwater mine their ID are
trained to do that so this would like
only further help the training and then
also abstract from Carnegie eventually
one day they want to be able to
reverse-engineer it whatever like the
technology that they make the mines and
they get people and they like leaving
stranded yes no for them to actually
give messages to the dolphin in their
own language google translator for
they're like falcons like the new school
Falcons what are the level of
intelligence of a dolphin it is above a
dog is above you man ha above a pig
because pigs applying smart I heard
they're like identical to humans I
forgot if it was physically like
internal organs Lee or mentally I forgot
which one it was here another I think it
was one of their humans of the senior
was hobbies wise the humans have to see
ok musically inclined I don't know how I
can find that that scale for you guys
aren't any wiser they're really smart
and so they're saying though that's the
waves often communicate with each other
it's similar to the way we communicate I
agree humans do because they even stop
for the other dolphin to speak but they
also we also like fun don't they for fun
yeah not just for Reproductive purposes
and we do that too I know I'm saved we
got mad stuff in common and you know
what they're presided children in the
folklore of Greek mythology something
that would you said they hold on say
you're saying like a dolphin will go by
and he goes back to it Tommy's like
you're on the go and they go by yeah
like if you forget she said something he
just goes all the way back it's like
y'all I forgot to tell you something and
it's Lamech
what I don't know if it's like that but
the way they communicate like a huge new
sound and I start like a certain sound
means a certain I guess I'd say word and
then they actually have ways to like
form sentences their own with their own
sounds $2 precision I think it sucks
that's why they use sonar but you do the
echolocation [ __ ] right you later
I wonder if yeah I know bad to that yeah
they use the echolocation idea I asked
to to know the distance
oh yeah Lee clicking yeah [ __ ] crazy
I wonder if that were split like a
dolphin face like you see the dogs I go
the other way I forgot what I watched
but it was like a pregnant lady in the
water in a dolphin and it I can't eat
anything
Iowa's oh yeah okay cuz the dolphin was
communicating something about the baby
or didn't knew that there was a baby
yeah somehow manage the pain for the mom
with like the delivery like I'm not
going to deliver in a [ __ ] pool full
of wild animal why not because it's my
child you have nothing to do with this
one no give me the reason because
they're wild animals that's all you need
what's wrong a wild animal wait what if
would it make you feel better if this
thing was like in full effect it's a
fully communicate with dolphins you know
what they're saying they know what
you're saying would that make you feel
better I know them 100% no because I
barely trust humans but what if it was
doctor dolphin yeah then I would yeah
yeah I would
good now they put in yeah they put in
their time and and I trust them that
screwed up not that Yelp reviews
yeah doctor dolphin like you've been
doing it for a while you know he's
changed you're not the first baby that
he's delivering I need at least five
reviews you're very right though because
if I don't give a [ __ ] about what a
person you want ok dolphin basically
what the hell I care more about dolphin
thinks than human think mmm that's
actually true too though I don't even
think about that I probably took care
more about what is obviously human
things but what if there was normal like
it's been done everyone knows like the
dolphin community is just like another
oh I'll be so mad if we got some
negative that dolphin comments is [ __ ]
oh that is cozy you too [ __ ] and
I would I would [ __ ] Japan harpoon
the [ __ ] out of those [ __ ] dude
dude hey guys hope you enjoyed that
episode please don't miss a beat and
subscribe if you don't subscribe you
don't know when a new video is uploaded
but for more videos click up here
[Music]